en tunisie maintenant le gouvernement
durcit ces mesures pour ralentir la
propagation du coït 19è les frontières
maritimes et aériennes ont été fermés
encore quelques passagers tentent en
vain de quitter le pays mais plus aucun
vol n'était assuré l heure est à la
décontamination des aéroports un
reportage de ben hassen chébili et rm
nasri un aéroport a déserté des vols
annulés le gouvernement tunisien a
renforcé ses mesures de prévention pour
lutter contre la propagation du courant
navires us pour les quelques passagers
qui restent à l'aéroport de
tunis-carthage l'objectif est de trouver
une solution pour quitter le territoire
et regagner leur pays
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
témoignages nous sommes polonais les
nous vivons en angleterre et nous
travaillons en angleterre donc nous
souhaitons juste rentré nous elle dit
qu'on pouvait juste se racheter un
billet pour le 14 mai pour le premier
vol disponible mais personne ne nous
apportent des solutions et solo chine il
est dit que l'on se retrouvait un billet
les comment trouver un billet que
l'aéroport
nous n'avons nulle part où aller
si on les autorise à dormir à l'aéroport
ne dormiront à la grand'porte moi je
suis venu enfin qu'en tunisie là on
l'espère ton passé des semaines de
vacances qui fait l'aller-retour je vais
le 3 et le retour chez les seize voilà
je programme et que je rentrais 16 les
chaises et ils m'ont pas prévenus et les
seize je suis parti en matière pour
prendre mon avion et a pas d'avion ils
m'ont dit faut que j'aille à l'aéroport
ici j'ai pris un rouage d'un taxi est
arrivé hier ils ont des places
je voulais pas me donner et je demandais
à la mode m'a passé à l'islam ils
veulent pas immédiats pas de place il va
pas me donner
et là je suis venu les chercher pour
rentrer chez moi
moi j'habite à lyon entrée en france
j'ai ma famille j'ai ma mise en grille
tout là bas nous travaille tout alors
qu'encore quelques passagers sont
toujours à l'extérieur de l'enceinte
espérons trouver une solution pour
regagner leur pays l'aéroport a décidé
de fermer ses portes et d'annuler tous
ses vols les autorités ont même déclaré
que les services sanitaires
interviendrez l aéroport une
décontamination a commencé ici et
devrait durer encore quelques jours
nous sommes
train de décontaminer tous les aéroports
les façades et les poignets porte avec
un produit spécial
il y a deux groupes un groupe qui
travaille le matin de 11h à 13h et un
deuxième groupe de 13 heures jusqu'à
tard le soir
c'est une opération quotidienne on a
commencé progressivement depuis à peu
près sept jours nous sommes neuf le
matin et plus de 15 d'après midi ce sont
tous les aéroports qui était contaminé
les terminaux et les pistes et même à
l'intérieur des avions nous des
contaminants toutes les zones
face à cette crise mondiale du
coronavirus et autorités à est une
hygiène adoptent de plus en plus des
dispositions drastiques pour lutter
contre la propagation de ce virus des
frontières maritimes fermées des
frontières aériennes fermées comme vous
pouvez voir autour de - l'aéroport qui a
été complètement déserté et des vols
annulés des équipes sanitaires sur place
pour désinfecter l'ensemble de terminaux
le gouvernement a mis en place un
confinement généralisé sur l'ensemble du
pays alors qu'on vient d'enregistrer un
60e cas d'infection ici dans le pays